Tên em nhìn hôm nay
Mysz trong vừa nó chất là
Đại edge mà
Thếm lấy nha này
ở nó nhiều anh
Tất em thấy sau lửa mà nби quá
Vừa mà lately
v bán của bán mình hộ ở nước bán
Mà nhất bà chanh
Điàn hồng recept
Vì đó họ ở đâu
hẹn g Peak đau
Vì hpture nó
là dạy dạy tế
Nói bà trời, nó ngon nói bà trời, nó ngon nói bà trời mất rõ, nó chứ có vọng
Chúng ta còn nổi chút cho ngọt muốn sợ cho rõ Đói
Không nắng nổi chứ mà nổi chút cho ngọt muốn giói bà
Vậy, nó có gì nơi của nó cũng bắt đông nhiều
Phải sẽ gặp tình chờ nó bắt màu ngọt ngay nữ không?
Thuy trời ngang nè và tìm lắm cách chào đúng đi vô
Vì có ngủ gì nơi sợng nè vậy?
Rồi bà trời, thì mình vẫn đọc nơi tâm từ rồi
Gán gất, mình phải mà vỏ hỗ
And the next thing is the broth.
Th cooked it all so it's a long, long or long time,
Th hit the quas.
Thì sao ăn kêu giảm ơn?
Thì chứ hảy ra cho kong chi doen qu nuo chứ.
Thì bây giờ thữa bao nhiêu rộn a cồi
Thì chứ lần 3,ich như thế này.
Chứ bây giờ gần 2,
đoạn bao nhiêu rộn,
đoạn dương.